what's going on you guys Lord ax here
coming at you for another review today
we're reviewing Mario plus rabbit's
spark of hopes now you guys know that
the first one I wasn't particularly
really thrilled with and I think a lot
of that was I felt like the diversity in
gameplay wasn't something that I would
expect from x-com Style game is this
XCOM no I would say this is more of the
gameplay from XCOM and the micromanaging
is not in place of this game so let's go
over a little bit about the story now I
will say the story is relatively okay I
don't think it's anything fantastic but
it's enough to keep you there all going
over it it's pretty much the story about
Mario and the rabbits taking on some
intergalactical Galaxy Beast that is in
the space somewhere just causing all
kinds of Havoc that's pretty much the
gist of the story I'm not gonna go too
much into spoiler territory but that's
pretty much what's going down here now
this this game is in voice act now out
I'm not gonna sit here and say that
every game should be voice hacked but I
do feel like if you have the money and
you're not putting it in to something
like this I don't know what you're doing
Nintendo needs to get on the 22nd
century in voice acting their characters
I'm sitting here when you actually go
through here and you play what's going
on the majority of it is just rambling
it's like that that you know Yakuza type
of stuff where they say something maybe
the first word of the sentence and then
that's all they really say for the
entire duration of that conversation now
it's like I said I understand people sit
there they make fun of me they say
addict why are you so big on voice
acting because I expect my games to have
a voice to the characters that's going
on especially from a company like
Nintendo but for some reason people feel
like me expecting Nintendo to get with
the program is somehow bad for everyone
I think Mario will leave G rabbit Mario
rabbit Luigi Bowser having a voice would
do this game wonders and I just don't
understand why either Nintendo Fanboys
or Nintendo themselves does not see this
as something that needs to be addressed
in 2022. as far as the story I do feel
like maybe the last planet could have
been shortened a little bit now for the
way that this system works out is it's
pretty much like a Kingdom Hearts where
you have worlds that you go to that have
their own internal struggles going on
now you do do things for the NPCs
throughout the world I do feel like if
you were gonna go this direction you
could have made the worlds more detailed
have a little bit more lively going on I
felt like for the most part the main
Narrative of that world is something
that was directed towards the
quote-unquote darkness that Mario and
you know the rabbits are facing in this
game but I never felt like the world had
their own ecosystem had their own
livelihood their own culture I felt like
it was strictly designed to carry The
Narrative of the actual Darkness plot
the main storyline and that's okay but
you know look at something like Kingdom
Hearts you know when you go into these
worlds and in Kingdom Hearts they have
their own culture they have their own
struggles that's going on in that world
and I felt like Ubisoft didn't take
advantage of building these worlds out I
don't understand why since Mario has a
Nintendo in general have all of these
worlds that they can do stuff with why
didn't they have that kind of Direction
while going into Mario rap it's maybe
it's something they want strictly to be
more towards this the score Enix with
Kingdom Hearts but I felt like you could
have did something a little bit better I
felt like the worlds in general just
could have been more open more detailed
have more NPCs have better quests and
side quests because majority of the side
quests literally are yo the technicals
are on this side can you please go get
them that's that's pretty much the
entire game really to be honest with you
that's why I felt like it kind of
outstated its welcome a little bit
because once you do that enough times
you kind of get tired of doing that but
besides the voiceovers and you know some
pacing in the games a little off
compared to other places I'm not gonna
sit here and say the pacing of the
game's bad I think the pacing's pretty
good it's just they could have did a
little bit better maybe make certain of
these areas a little shorter and I felt
like it would have carried on a lot
better than it did to me now let's talk
about the performance of Mario plus
rabbits Sparks a hopes on the Nintendo
switch it's horrible I'm not gonna sit
here and say that it was like the worst
experience I've ever felt on the switch
there's definitely worse but at this
point playing this game Nintendo you
need to make another switch aeration and
needs to be stronger it felt like every
time I did certain things like a Luigi
rabbit has like this special that you
can do where he like pretty much break
dance and puts and brings everyone's
weakness down that glitched and looked
like a PowerPoint almost every time I
did it thank God I didn't use him to the
very end of the game but I was so
annoyed every time I used them because
I'm like how did Ubisoft feel like this
was appropriate to run like look I get
it maybe they were doing everything they
can there's only so much you can do with
a system like the switch but at this
point I mean what the switch came out in
2017 18 19 21 22. four years that's
still pretty low in on the scale in
terms of consoles but as far as a
handheld just just upgrade you know I'm
not trying to be rude on this matter but
we've had it enough where you can
upgrade and I don't think people is
going to get upset especially if you
announced it like when Zelda the new
Zelda comes out I can't imagine what the
news out is going to run like if Mario
plus rabbits ran like this then again
Nintendo's in-house studios are going to
be making that and they probably know
how to work their way around the
Nintendo switch's actual builds better
than Ubisoft would so maybe it will run
a little bit better on the Nintendo
switch compared to Mario and rabbits ran
on it but it's just like at that point
you know it's probably going to be 30
frames I hate running games at 30 frames
and it's just like at this point it's
like I said new Switch Nintendo get with
the program now let's talk about
gameplay you guys know that when it
comes to games usually game plays what I
put above everything else story is
important but I feel like gameplay is
going to keep you interactive with the
actual product story will only get you
so far if you don't like playing the
game most likely you're just going to
look up the cutscenes from the game
going forward so you don't have to play
that gameplay now if you guys don't like
the x-com style gameplay I don't know
why you're here I said that at the
beginning I feel like the majority of
people know this game has that type of
gameplay and I do think they do it well
so Mario and Rabbit's the first one had
a pretty standard x-com style game they
had it to where you go to one block
another block you fight you got two
things they kind of change it up on
Mario and rabbits and I actually I don't
think it was better but I don't think it
was worse when I saw this grid space
initially I felt like they took a lot of
the turn based out of it but no it's
it's still very much there now let me
explain what I mean and Mario rabbits
Sparks of hopes you pretty much have
this diameter around you this uh AOE if
you will if you guys play those type of
games where you can move around anywhere
freely in that section that you want to
and why does that matter I think that
they wanted to go towards more movement
and the reason I feel like that is
because there's a lot of characters in
this game that have increased dashes
there's characters in this game such as
Mario that allow you to jump on an
enemy's head multiple times if you
upgrade it and the re the way to do that
is to move your character to a specific
point on there so they can bounce off
that and do a team jump I feel like
they're very vocal with this this is the
way they want the game to play for
certain characters I think Mario is one
of these characters he was designed to
do movement and then do shooting second
and the reason I think that is because
Mario has like a huge and detailed Tree
on his OverWatch ability and what the
OverWatch ability to me is is just
pretty much a special where if an enemy
moves during their turn he will shoot
them they have an entire tree dedicated
to Mario with that so I feel like that's
how this character has moved and I think
the majority of them were structured
around this to some degree there are new
characters in this game that allow you
to do it you know there are characters
that you wouldn't expect in this game
that have huge hit points when they
actually Dash into enemies now all the
mark designed for this way you know
Luigi for example is a sniper he does
have an over watch ability which is
interesting that pretty much everyone
that's special is some form of OverWatch
ability they wanted you to do a lot more
shooting on the opponent's turn and I
respect that I feel like the movement
system gives this enough you know
uniqueness where it's not quite like
x-com it's its own little thing and they
put the Mario system in here because
what's Mario always been about since the
time of the day it's a platformer you
jump on pumba's heads you jump over
blocks
that is kind of what this game similarly
is now obviously it's not a a platformer
it's a turn-based game but I do feel
like they put some of that Essence that
belongs in Mario in this game and I have
to respect them for that because a lot
of companies love to take formulas from
other franchises or other Publishers and
developers in general and I feel like
they don't really add too much of their
own to it they just Jack the core basics
of that other development Studios
process and they don't add anything to
it but I felt like they did enough to
the x-com style in this to make it their
own this is a Mario turn-based game and
I think a lot of you would enjoy this
particularly another thing I have to
really give them props for is just the
leveling system in this game entirely
when you defeat enemies or defeat a
mission in this game you get levels up
clearly you get experience you get these
things called like these rainbow coins I
can't remember exactly their name that's
that's what you level up the Sparks with
we're going to talk about here in a
minute and what I like about this is it
levels everyone up and not just the
character and the team that you use
there's other games that don't do this
octopath traveler does not do this so
when you get to scenarios in the game
where it's forcing you to use all of the
members in your team you are stuck with
people that you've used the whole game
and people that you haven't used any of
the games pretty much uh sure there's
people that probably use all of the
characters they switch them in and out
but I would say mostly the people that
play this game stick to four people that
they have good symmetry with and they
stick to them for the periodically the
entirety of the game now there are
scenarios in other games where they
force you to use other characters and
Sparks does have this you know Sparks of
Hope says certain side quests forcing
you to use maybe Peach and rabbit Peach
I hate these missions because a lot of
the time the characters aren't balanced
I feel like they just did this to add
content and these are the difficult
missions in Mario Sparks and hopes
because they're forcing to use
characters that you wouldn't normally
use most likely and on top of that
they're forcing you to use characters
that aren't necessarily working good
together the reason I'm not going to
really go at them too much for that is I
feel like that's more of challenging
yourself kind of thing and it's not
necessarily you have to do it to
continue the story so I feel like that
was done intentionally they want you to
challenge yourself to how to use these
characters correctly or the way they
envisioned it and that's okay with me
one thing I really wish Ubisoft was
would do if they make another one of
these is let me have four people four
people it's not hard the remissions in
this game are you used four people I
don't understand why they can't just let
me four people I get it three is
probably a good number for them maybe
there's no more that can be work than
past three on the switch maybe it's
performance issues that they stick with
three people and not four Terror was the
entire game I just feel like four units
to be able to to use leads to more
diversity in gameplay at least the more
strategy you can use between characters
three you can still have access to these
combos access to these unique aspects of
gameplay but I don't feel like it's
enough to make me really want to go and
explore because you only have three
people so you know Ubisoft if you're
able to if you make another one of these
let me have four people I feel like the
majority of people watching this video
would agree having four people leads to
a lot more variety of type of gameplay
and combos that you can do in the game
and that leads to the you know the other
great aspect of Mario rabbits Sparks of
Oaks it's the Sparks I feel like that's
the missing piece that made me really
enjoy avoid this one over the previous
one and and the reason I think that is
because with the Sparks the added
elements in the game and I'm not saying
there wasn't any form of element
weaknesses in the last one I don't think
there was but there might have been that
I overlooked but in this one they just
plainly tell you look if you're fighting
a water opponent use this spark that
gives you lightning attributes to your
attacks use this Gus that gives you wind
attributes to this attack now what's
cool is all of them doesn't do it there
are certain Sparks of that element they
give you AOE attacks and I think it's a
good variety of gameplay I think that
was the key thing of this game that made
this unique and different from the
original one and really made it stand
out from games like XCOM is the fact
that it's got an element system in it
it's got a weakness system in it and I
like things like that because it adds
variety of gameplay to the actual games
for instance you can do stuff like when
you're Luigi you can do the gustability
when you know there's a bunch of people
weak to that around you and if they're
in full cover which is a hundred percent
you're missing you can set OverWatch up
and as long as you don't shoot you have
enough points to do that because you
only got two points every term or two
action points every turn and as long as
you just do the lightning ability or the
gustability and you do the OverWatch
when that person leaves that cover
they're gonna get hit by you I think
that gives you a lot of variety in
gameplay there is people in here that if
you add the Sparks to them they become
utterly broken and it's not just
attributes and weaknesses and elements
there's abilities on here to revive with
Sparks there's Sparks in here that give
you abilities like invisible you could
turn invisible so if you want to make
tank characters and go in there and do
as much damage as possible and then pop
up that last action point to go
invisible that is a gameplay style that
is available to you because of these
Sparks and I really love the Sparks and
the variety of gameplay they gave you in
this game and you know most of the time
I would never bring up last bosses I
know I couldn't spoil anything so no one
you know
freak out and click off the video what I
want to really say is they did a really
well last boss in this game and I feel
like anyone that gets to that last boss
they're challenging they have a lot of
aspects and challenges that you wouldn't
normally have in these type of games and
I like people being different and I feel
like the last boss in this game is very
different another thing that was kind of
weird on this is the weapons seem to be
entirely Cosmetics they had no stats
behind them whatsoever I didn't really
like that if that was the case because I
felt like it took away some of the
Strategic points that the previous one
had it's just like look like you can
give me weapons that have stats on them
we're not in 1990 you know we can have
stats on weapons maybe they did it to
casualize the game a little bit more to
make it more approachable for people
where they only have to really worry
about what sparks they have and what
their ability trees have which obviously
this game has ability trees it's got RPG
mechanics in general so I don't feel
like it's lacking them but I've always
felt like weapons is the sinner of an
RPG where what kind of weapon do you
have on and look all the weapons are
preset you can't change any weapons for
the most part Luigi's gonna have the
sniper rifle Mario's gonna have the Dual
pistols but I do feel like they could
have had stats that made certain Sparks
better or worse I feel like that could
have been an easy route they could have
done it doesn't really take away from
the game because I do feel like they did
such a good job with the the tree on
here and the sparks in general and how
they collab with each other but I do
feel like it could have added more of a
Centric point on the RPG system and made
it a little bit more in-depth maybe make
it a special mode that you don't have to
actually go with but you can go with the
standard one that we played now but if
you want to have a little bit more of an
RPG Tree in it you can go that direction
too but to conclude you know people ask
addict I've heard you talk for 17
minutes what is your opinion on if you
should buy this game you guys know I
don't give numbers on anything I feel
like numbers take away from the actual
points of the review I would say this is
a buy you know even at sixty dollars if
you like these XCOM style games it is a
very easy game to get into it's very fun
it's got a lot of cool aspects got a lot
of you know pretty decent sized puzzles
and even though that some of the pacing
was a little off I never felt like it
was enough to make you turn this game
off it has fantastic gameplay and I feel
like if you have never played the style
game it's something that is casual
enough that you can actually enjoy it
but it's not casual enough that people
that love this style of gameplay can
actually play and enjoy and I feel like
that's a really good balance that
Ubisoft has seemed to have done and my
hats off to them I do think this is
worth your money and I think you should
go out there and try it I would prefer
coming to the PC Ubisoft because I feel
like it would run way better but most
likely it's not if you want to play this
game go on switch if you're a little bit
on the fence now myself would definitely
pay for this game and I feel like if you
you like this type of gameplay you would
like it to but I understand
Black Friday coming up maybe you should
wait for that too I'm particularly one
of those people where I can't wait I'm
that type of gamer that I want to play
the new stuff now and if you're that
type of gamer don't wait for this game
just go out there and buy it I think
it's a good game and I think it's worth
your 60 bucks but anyway tell me what
you guys think in the comment section
below did you guys enjoy the first one
are you thinking about picking up the
second one very curious to hear you
guys's opinion put it in the comment
section below and until the next review
this is Lord addict we're out of here
peace